bad [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
there was someone like Heather there's
no question about it
she says on many things a rapper an
economist a journalist a writer
and a dirty dirty dirty dirty hoe
is this a joke if it is a joke is is it
funny the department has charged Ilya
Liechtenstein and Heather Morgan for
their alleged roles in a conspiracy to
launder stolen cryptocurrency taken
during the 2016 hack of a virtual
currency exchange it's almost like
you're watching a movie unfold
when Heather and Dutch were arrested we
realized that this was possibly the
biggest heist in the history of the
world when we looked at it we were like
wait
this is the alleged conspirator of a
billion dollar crypto Heist
bitfinex is one of the biggest
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
in August 2016 bitfinex got hacked
somebody broke into their computer
system and was able to access the keys
which are like the cryptographic
passwords to the Bitcoins that they hold
for their customers and they transferred
these Bitcoins to other wallets and
before anyone noticed what happened
about half the exchanges Bitcoin had
been transferred
so bitfinex had to shut down the
exchange obviously the customers were
really worried they announced that
they'd been hacked and that a lot of the
customer funds were lost
the hacker stole 119
754 Bitcoins I believe at one point the
pile was worth as much as 8 billion just
like an insane amount of money for
anyone to have
this is a story that very much plays out
on social media and I think that is the
reason why it hit our desk tonight I
want to talk about the Bitcoin bit uh
bitfenix hackers or money launderers
something doesn't feel right and I will
show you what people have found when I
started Googling like everybody else on
the internet I realized that they didn't
seem like the sharpest criminals in this
episode we're talking about these two
idiots
what really triggered our interest was
these videos that started going around
showing Heather Morgan who is one of the
alleged conspirators in this crypto
Heist rapping about being the crocodile
of Wall Street in these really
weird music videos that were all of a
sudden making rounds across social media
Wall Street
the Bitcoin crimes are nothing compared
to calling this rap I definitely wanted
to dig into it and no more
Heather grew up in a Tiny Town in
California it was about a couple hundred
people that lived there and as she was
living there she really craved getting
out growing up I did not have a lot of
friends and it was really hard because
no one was trying to do the things I
wanted to do professionally as far as
entrepreneurship technology seeing the
world and as soon as to graduated she
got out of the country she did a short
stint in Hong Kong and then found her
way in Cairo where she was trying to get
a master's degree in international
economics but remember this was back in
2011 this was a time when Tech was
really taking off San Francisco was
really booming and I think for her it
really became clear very soon that if
she wanted to become something she had
to move back to California
foreign
I met Heather about eight years ago at
500 startups it's a startup incubator
based out of the Bay Area man I haven't
seen these faces for so long that's a
good picture it is right there you can
see right everybody's like I'll beat
everybody's optimistic and everybody's
looking for that you know next break
Heather really enjoyed that environment
she was very in tune with you know
everybody what's going on around her
interacting with all these different
kinds of people different Founders
different investors VCS mentors she was
always there personality was like super
friendly very bubbly very ambitious very
helpful she was like a fish in water
there this principal who was also my
teacher he told me listen
you're a big fish in a small pond
but if you go to the ocean you might
drown the ocean yeah it's big but I'm a
shark I belong in the ocean not in a mud
puddle or a pond
that's around the time that she meets
Ilya Lichtenstein who goes by Dutch my
name is
Dutch is someone who grew up in Chicago
but was born in Russia his family were
Russian immigrants and he really was
someone who in high school was
describing himself as a nerd he was
captain of the math team and really
didn't have you know really good social
skills when he was in college I saw that
he'd posted a lot on forums about
affiliate marketing and this is sort of
like the the Shady Side of internet
marketing where you're posting ads about
like miracle diet pills or like can't
miss investment tips I think his
specialty was adult dating sites he was
bragging that when he was in college he
was making more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year from this affiliate
marketing
Dutch then went from that to starting a
company that was in this internet
marketing space that was more legit they
raised money from some Angel Investors
well we're at a really exciting place as
a company right now because we are at a
point where we have initial product
Market fit we have good Revenue growth
we have over 100 customers according to
reports that we saw out there even
though Duchess company
super well one day in 2016 he just quit
he packed up all his things with Heather
and they moved to New York City and I
think that became a really interesting
date for prosecutors as well because
that's around the time when the bitfinex
hack happened
the reality is that a lot of those hacks
are not the most sophisticated hacks
that you would see in the cyber security
space a lot of them really rely on
social engineering and that's kind of
the entry point for the hackers to
obtain access to the internal systems
the I.T infrastructure of the compromise
Target in Social Engineering attacks the
victim which is usually the employee of
the company is being persuaded by the
hackers through some kind of an email
message a phone call sometimes even a
video chat to do some interaction which
will open Mauritius files on their
desktop or laptop I've been writing
forever and I've been sending cold
emails at least sending one a day for
more than 10 years now so I've
definitely written more than 10 000 cold
emails and once that file is open the
attackers are able to implant and to
install a malware that once installed
provides them full access to that
computer I like to do what I call
e-stocking going on LinkedIn Twitter
works too if they're on Twitter and if
that computer is not properly isolated
and has access to the entire network
they are able to propagate to other
components in the network or to access
other really sensitive resources and a
little Pro tip for LinkedIn is to look
on their references who they're
referring and who has referred them
because those are actually really rich
with keywords and gives you a good sense
of how they talk that was also the case
in the bitfenix acts but also like you
know in many hacks that you see even
today Heather embarks on a multitude of
different activities including running
her tech company and it essentially
offers businesses services for cold
emailing and for branching out and
marketing we can influence people a lot
of ways you can influence them with
flattery by adding value to them writing
it
also influence here and so she's going
around New York and she's actually
giving talks and presentations to people
who are showing up to hear her advice
and in 2019 perhaps one of the most
notable ones was one that she gave at
the Williamsburg hotel called how to
social engineer your way into anything
social hearing is basically
I hate the term manipulating but it's
it's getting someone to share
information or take an action that they
otherwise would not and some of these in
hindsight just were all very funny
because it was almost like she's telling
on herself
I mean she's great at Cold emails she's
great at manipulating people is it such
a stretch to think that she could have
participated in you know sending a
phishing email to a crypto Exchange
as soon as they moved to New York City
they ended up living in an apartment on
Wall Street it was a million dollar
apartment it's like a pretty normal
looking apartment well no it's not
normal looking at all because Heather
decorated it the apartment's full of
like weird knickknacks that she's
collected like crocodile skulls or
something she called Ukrainian sewer
rocks they had an elliptical but she
painted it like a zebra
I mean they seem like they have a lot of
fun together like around the financial
district traveling going to restaurants
it wasn't like they were living like a
billionaire lifestyle but they were
definitely spending a fair amount of
money
you'd think that somebody who allegedly
laundered billions of dollars would try
to keep a low profile but Heather
actually seemed to be trying to turn
herself into some kind of like
internet famous personality
Heather started appearing across social
media with an alter Eagle that Alter Ego
was named rosacan and she was a rapper
moon in Stars we don't own cars the
pandemic in the pandemic party like a
beiruti lab and tabouli [ __ ]
there are a few people I've come across
in my life that you just say like
there's nobody like that
um there's one of them she was a
frequent guest at our Gallery she was
fun she was always entertaining good to
be around I remember distinctly
the day she told me that she wanted to
become a hip-hop artist and then started
to rap and when I heard that those words
that's what shocked me
they were some of the most vile
mind-blowing Concepts it fits totally
into Heather it's it's just
Unapologetic she
rapped about
smoking her grandfather's ashes at a
graveyard that was colorful
masturbating a horse
but also
rapt about Finance Bros and like on Wall
Street and misogyny and all those things
it was almost a challenge it was how can
you keep a straight face when she is
keeping a straight face
freestyling being completely who she is
and she was really serious about being a
hip-hop artist but also I couldn't keep
myself composed
she would kind of smirk when I was
smirking but she wasn't joking about
this stuff
your real self is always your best
selfie those
[Music]
I never really thought about where she's
getting the money from but when I heard
the music the first thing that did
come into my head was who's paying for
this production it's not that bad
production it has to cost some money
I love you I support you but I don't
want to be involved
to private club and you ain't in it
Dutch is sort of in the background he's
like reluctantly on camera he kind of
complains about it so then you just keep
filming me expecting something to happen
and what do you want me to do you want
me to just like shove something up my
ass once he decided to propose to her he
essentially hired a marketing agency to
put up posters of Rosal Khan around New
York City the campaign described Heather
as someone who captured the essence of
rosalcon surreal mysterious creepy and
sexy
I think the fact that they really sort
of craved that attention was also
visible at their wedding with social
media videos that circulated from the
day of the ceremony showing Heather
rapping throughout the ceremony but
perhaps the most interesting thing was
that she was carried down the aisle
while sitting on a throne by eight
people while Final Countdown was playing
on the background
Heather and Dutch they would have known
something was up because they'd been
notified by their internet service
provider that someone had asked for
their records through a legal request
after the hack bitfinex publicized the
addresses that the hackers had used this
was to put everybody on alert so that
they didn't do any deals with those
Bitcoins it's almost like
setting off the die pack in the bag of
stolen money after a bank robbery so the
hackers had all these Bitcoins but
be difficult to find someone who wanted
to handle them because now they're sort
of marked as dirty money
so they needed some sort of less ethical
player that didn't mind accepting
payments from their marked accounts and
for five months the coins didn't move at
all
then they found somebody who was willing
to take at least some of them this less
picky business was called Alpha Bay kind
of like a eBay on the dark web where you
can buy drugs guns whatever so obviously
the administrator of this underworld
eBay tried to keep his identity secret
as it turned out it was a 25 year old
Canadian named Alexander causes who was
living in Thailand so the bitfinex
hackers first sent funds to Alpha Bay in
January 2017. what they didn't know is
that Alpha Bay was already the target of
this International investigation called
operation bayonet and just a few months
later in July
Royal Thai police
braided causes is compound and so they
were able to access all of alpha Bay's
files
when you send the money to alphabet
you're like sending it into this box and
when you withdraw it no one can tell
like where it came from exactly but now
the FBI has the Box they look inside and
they can make all the connections
between the deposits and the withdrawals
so if you are able to track that the
cryptocurrency transactions and
eventually the hacker is sloppy or
didn't really think about how they're
going to cash out the cryptocurrency
that they were able to steal then they
would authenticate themselves with a
financial institution let's say a
centralized exchange a fintech app or
something like that through which they
will try to convert say the Bitcoins to
regular cash the police or the law
enforcement agencies can now identify
who was trying to basically cash out the
funds at least in some cases some of the
money went to accounts that had been
opened by Dutch using his real name
Brazil probably he thought this would
never be traced back to the Hacked funds
but the rate on Alpha Bay
I think made it possible to make the
connection 94
000 Bitcoin that is 3.6 billion dollars
in Tuesday police in New York arrested a
husband and wife couple that allegedly
tried to launder just that amount when
the indictment came out I got a text
message from my business partner being
like you need to see this I clicked on
it and I saw a picture it just popped up
right there saying okay uh such and such
but then I said
Heather Morgan I know that name and then
when I clicked on it you know their
photo was there I was like oh my
goodness
this blew my mind I immediately message
her I'm like dude what's going on it was
January 5th 2022.
Heather's parents were visiting and
obviously Heather and Dutch had no idea
that these agents were coming on this
day these FBI and IRS agents come into
Heather's and Dutch's apartment and
start taking their electronic devices
the agents described the search in a
court filing and at some point Heather
says this is taking a long time we'd
like to leave but can we take our Bengal
cat chloritha with us she crouches down
next to the bed
and tries to get Clarissa out but it was
actually kind of a trick because what
she really wanted to do was grab her
cell phone off the nightstand she starts
hitting lock but the agents are right
there able to get the cell phone from
her they found burner phones haul it out
books all sorts of electronics the
authorities had also gotten warrants to
search Dutch's cloud storage accounts
and in this they found evidence that
they had been preparing fake identities
it looked like maybe they were planning
to flee the country and by the end of
the month on January 31st they were able
to
crack the encryption to one of his files
which had all the passwords to the
Bitcoin wallets that held the stolen
Bitcoins
this was like the jackpot this is what
they were looking for because it doesn't
necessarily prove that
Dutch was the hacker but somehow he'd
come into possession of these passwords
and whoever has the passwords controls
the Bitcoins and by this point they're
worth billions of dollars and so all of
a sudden these two quirky awkward
individuals that post seemingly you know
innocent videos across social media have
become these two individuals that
allegedly conspire to launder 4.5
billion dollars in crypto what the doj
describes as their largest financial
seizure ever
[Music]
I couldn't believe it it didn't seem
real knowing the kind of person she is
she's kind she's thoughtful she's
interesting she's all these things but
maybe she she doesn't realize that this
isn't a movie I'm not defending anything
right people do weird things and some
take it too far
in terms of General scrutiny that the
women have to go through
is definitely much harder than guys and
that's same with Heather's case now I
see is that everybody's just focused on
the entertainment aspect of it you ever
want to get first thing that came out is
all about oh you know look at you know
the rapping and this and that probably
crazy so immediately the objectivity of
the case itself is kind of lost
[Music]
in the crypto World almost nothing
shocks me anymore
but this was definitely pretty
surprising this is a world where all
sorts of peoples are getting rich and
then losing it overnight
you have a crypto scam you have Tick
Tock videos going viral you have that
hype and that need to be sort of a
celebrity across social media and so
really these are all the forces that
came together to create a crypto Heist
that was made for the digital times
I would say that the big exchanges seem
to have tightened their security but
then the hackers have also stepped up
their game we are seeing the hackers
really moving into the area of D5
protocol we have three organizations
gaming companies that are using
cryptocurrencies because they are the
new targets for them the fact that
social engineering still happens today
and it's the number one entry point
that's definitely true
I went down to the courthouse where
Heather and Dutch would have gone for
their pre-trial hearing and on a traffic
poll right across from where she likely
would have walked into court there was a
sticker one of the same ones that she
posted all over the financial district
that showed razzlecon riding a crocodile
who knows maybe she's riding that
crocodile off into the sunset for
Average Joe's everyone knows
ready to party down and let's get weird
moon and stars moon and stars
[Music]